Europe's General Affairs Council will
prepare this week for a summit of EU
leaders in March putting the spotlight
on climate change energy and the economy
the leaders are set to debate her
proposed framework for energy for the
2022 2030 period and to examine how much
has been done to implement energy
recommendations they handed down in May
at their meeting on the twentieth and
twenty-first of March heads of state and
government will assess progress that
member states have made in implementing
budget recommendations the
recommendations from the European
Commission a part of the so-called
European semester process which is aimed
at helping nations to strengthen their
budget and economic policies the leaders
are also likely to debate ways to
strengthen Europe's industrial base so
that it can help to spur economic growth
and create more jobs relations with
Africa and the EU Africa summit in April
are also on the agenda the General
Affairs Council will also appraise the
Greek presidencies priorities for its
term at the helm which include improving
civic and society engagement in the EU
reinforcing Europe's democratic
legitimacy and accountability and
deepening monetary union finally the
ministers will discuss a proposal to
authorize the cultivation of a
genetically modified type of maize the
council must pronounce itself on this
subject by the twelfth of februari